for a next fireside chat were honored to
welcome Scott cook founder and chairman
of the executive committee of Intuit
Scott is a member of the board of
directors of Procter & Gamble the
Harvard Business School Dean's Advisory
Board the Center for brand and product
management at the University of
Wisconsin and the Intuit
Scholarship Foundation and significantly
he's a sought-after mentor teacher and
admired leader here in Silicon Valley he
is joined by our own founder Sebastian
Thrun
who probably needs no introduction just
in case for the many in live stream and
all of you he's previously founder of
Google X where he led self-driving car
Google glass and many other projects
early on he led the Stanford racing team
whose robot Stanley won the DARPA Grand
Challenge
Sebastian continues as a research
professor at Stanford University and
most importantly he has been a teacher
to many of us here in this room today
please join me in welcoming Scott and
Sebastian
[Applause]
[Music]
hi everybody it's great to see so many
familiar faces a lot of our classes
it's an incredible glidin honor to have
with me a person I truly admire Scott
has been in many ways a founding father
of Silicon Valley 35 years ago created
one of a top fortune 500 companies said
it's fair to be important today into it
but it's also a great mentor to go to to
ask hard questions how to be a CEO and
so on so what I want to start with the
origins 35 years ago you found Intuit
what was very at that time hmm Silicon
Valley yeah 35 years ago well there
wasn't a TV show named after it it
really was a lot of silicon which you
don't see today much in the valley other
than Intel but I'd say the biggest
difference was the belief or role of
computing technology at the time it was
viewed as a an industrial product bought
by corporations there was there are many
people saying computers would never be
used in homes or by regular civilians
that this was for these were for
corporations it's one of the reasons why
we got no venture capital not a singer
single venture capitalist decided to
invest because we were saying no we're
doing stuff for regular people to use at
home and that was outside the paradigm
other than computer gaming and I think
that's the biggest difference today so
much of what happens in computing
affects our daily lives as individuals
and that's a giant shift in computing so
you stayed honest founding CEO for 11
years and we just had a chat offline
that he decided to step back give us the
beef
yeah so Tom and I got together 35 years
ago this month and I was the CEO and he
was the technical leader who ran the
engineering we struggled I mean this was
not an idea that our original product
was quicken personal finance management
of your checkbook and bill paying and
this was not an idea that and our
approach that one that got many fans we
got no good press we couldn't get
distributors to sell the software so we
went through hell and we almost went
under we had to stop paying salaries at
one point give back all the rented
furniture we had to bring in card tables
and fold up chairs and we use crates of
unsold product as printer stands and we
had lots of unsold product so we had
lots of that but eventually we got
through that the business took off and
started tripling tripled in size year
after year after year after year and it
got to the point where the company was
growing faster than I was and I could
see it and in moments of honesty the
people who work for me would tell me and
I felt I was holding the company back
and after all the hell we'd been through
or we almost lost it I didn't want to be
the one preventing us from getting to
the great future so I thought I needed
to hire somebody to run the company who
had the skills I didn't it was kind of
my compliment my my offset and so we
proceeded to looked at a CEO search and
I just - one thing I particularly felt I
was not good at was growing our people
helping them build the skills and our
leaders to grow the skills of leadership
and I wanted to get somebody who could
understand what they needed to grow and
help them learn to be the best they
could be
I was looking for a great coach and I
wound up hiring a guy named Bill
Campbell who later became known in the
valley as of a coach and thank God I did
but if I had to go back to the root
cause the root cause and this is maybe
one of my greatest mistakes I should
have gotten a coach myself and not at
that point but years before and I've
since in Wow it's a longer story I since
got a coach 12 years ago and I may be a
lot of I mean I if the greatest athletes
in the world whether it's Tiger Woods
the greatest baseball football players
need a coach well what about us regular
civilians so we all need a feedback loop
on us and someone to give us the tough
love we need to get better and I think
that's the root cause of why I wasn't
keeping up that makes me really want a
higher coach tomorrow morning your
people will thank you no one has given
me that feedback yet so you I you I find
this incredibly remarkable honesty for
the audience there's so much modesty and
humbleness in Silicon Valley that
sometimes we overlook how important it
is to be able to learn and I'm you're
such a role model to me I am in that boy
I need a coach right now so you hired
Bill Campbell who became advisor to
Larry Page and many other great CEOs and
then of course Bill Sayle recently
passed away but you've been to multiple
CEOs what when you when you get to the
stage to say look my great business
needs another CEO but what do you look
for but what is soon but I first have to
say that I don't think Larry needed much
advice Larry by the way it says is the
best thing ever happened to him mmm yeah
yeah I might disagree I can't stand for
him but so what yeah so I've hired or
participate in the hiring of eight CEOs
I think across three different companies
somebody did some research on CEOs and
they found there dramatically different
they don't
fit a common pattern some have great
strengths in one area others have great
strengths in another area but this
researcher said underneath it all they
found one characteristic that tended to
be common among the very best CEOs and I
think it's the thing that I look for
their ability to well do the thing that
I wasn't very good at doing self
learning to self critique and be
constantly learning because whatever
your job in a company is it's gonna
change and grow and your environment is
gonna change in your needs and if you're
not growing from your experience and if
you're not your own best feedback loop
then you're not growing the yourself to
be able to handle the job better and
better and I have to say Brad Smith
who's into it's C you know is one of the
most phenomenal self learners I have
ever met
so one thing you do as a CEO of a public
company is you do an earning so I'm
gonna tell story you do an earnings
conference call every quarter where you
get on the phone your CFO tells the
financial results and then you the CEO
give your gloss on the quarter just
finished and to answer questions from
the investors it's something you get no
practice doing prior to that because
nobody else is on the call other than
the CEO and the CFO so we did our first
earnings conference call with Brad as
the new CEO and I sat back and watched
him perform and I thought he was
spectacular particularly on the Q&A part
so that we finished the call we do a
quick debrief and he says Scott what
could I have done better and I said well
gosh Brad I'm pretty picky on these
things and have high standards and I
actually saw all the things you did well
I I don't have any suggestions next
morning he comes in I said Scott I've
thought about it I see three things I
could have done better he'd clearly
listened to the transcript overnight
that they saved that you can listen to
on your phone and he said here are the
three things I could have done better
and by god he was right
everyone that's the power of a self
learner and I think that's the most
important characteristic maybe not just
for CEOs maybe maybe for all of us
I very much agree let's see let's turn
to technology you've seen your business
transform from the 1980s to today and
you see new things coming up be
blockchain artificial intelligence
cybersecurity what is on your mind right
now when it comes to new technologies
hmm you know I start with assessing how
well are we doing and and frankly I'd in
terms of solving customers problems
which is kind of our business we exist
to solve the the problems that our
customers small businesses and consumers
have I've frankly would give us a grade
of much improvement needed I mean so
it's tax season here in the US and any
TurboTax users in the audience raise
your hand good awesome thank you thank
you
so taxes in the US personal income tax
is an ugly long process with lots of
data and information we still make our
customers do too much work you have to
sit there and answer a bunch of
questions you should have no work it
should know about you already we should
be able to find all the data and be able
to use AI to figure out exactly what
your situation is and ask you only if we
can't figure it out ourselves so the
taxes should be done in minutes with
virtually no work and we're not there
yet we've got a lot of work to do it's
AI it's data it's sensing it's a whole
bunch of stuff it's the fundamental we
rewrote our tax engine to be an AI based
engine so that we can throw any inputs
at it and it can alter it's not
procedural and sequenced like other tax
engines so that now opens us up to be
able to entirely reform the experience
same thing we start a small business
with us you shouldn't have to type
stuff in we should find your business
track record out in the larger world and
have that instantly pop up so with no
work we're providing answers about your
business so I I just frankly think we're
finally to the point when we started
people did not have digital footprints
out there that we could go find and
harvest and used to their benefit
everything had to be typed in but today
we've got no excuse we should be on this
I'm looking forward for the Dave and tax
season is not a headache for me anymore
please make it happen as fast as
possible because that's our job and
that's our duty and that's our may our
pay any of our fee perhaps our goal is
to power prosperity around the world
well if people have to be dragged
through the guts of doing taxes we're
not powering prosperity and we should
make the money come to you and get your
tax refund without you having to work
for it there's people in the world who
say every company has been hacked and
you either know about it a lot but
you've been hacked have you guys been
hacked there have been many attempts
well we have not been hacked in any
important way we were accused of being
hacked
there were there was theft of IDs not
theft from us from other places that was
used by some nefarious folks to file tax
returns in the US on behalf of Americans
and then get the tax refund and then the
honest citizen would come in and try to
file their taxes and the IRS would say
no you already filed a well wait a
minute so we were accused of that by the
federal government in a number of states
and we were able to establish that no
that was not us that was and then we
worked for them very closely now on
procedures to try to detect fraudulent
tax returns again applying data and AI
because only the government can be the
one to say no you can't file we can't
tell you that so we arm them with the
tools to be able to do them do you think
going forward that cybersecurity threat
will become much more daunting for
business like yours or do you think that
we are at a sad moment right now but
we're going to get on top of these
I think it's like history of warfare
where the defense's get better so the
attack gets better and then defenses get
better the attack gets better it's a
constant you know particularly in a
world of state-sponsored
mass cyberattacks where some of the best
and brightest in some countries are
hired and trained to work you know you
can see the patterns of attacks coming
during working hours in China and you
can see where they come from so it's a
business in some countries and
state-sponsored so I yes I think it's
gonna keep going like this and so we got
to be on our toes and have the best
people and and then be prepared to have
everything insulated isolated so that if
something happens the blast radius is
small so we've had to refactor all a
whole bunch of the way we manage our
data to keep it in with our Israeli team
we've put in some really fancy stuff to
keep it very small very rapidly changing
and yet keep the performance up so it
can serve our serve our customers so
since we have so many amazing graduates
and students in the audience I need to
ask this question what are you because
hiring needs right now
what do hiring needs hiring needs very
most desperate hire well let me let me
come at the question a couple of ways so
I was asked a similar question a group
of us last Tuesday night here in the
valley were at dinner with the founder
of the Kipp schools co-founder and this
is a group of a very successful chain of
charter schools almost entirely with
disadvantaged students in poor
neighborhoods and he opened the dinner
by saying I have a question if I came to
you with a group of couple hundred are
our top performing in math and science
students in the middle school what would
you tell me to do at the school in
middle school in high school so that
when they graduate
College they'll get a great job with
your company well the audience the group
of us ten of us were like either
silenced I think nobody was prepared for
such a big question undaunted by silence
I jumped in and said well I would forget
focusing on your top hundred or 200 you
should be doing something for all your
students and if I was gonna recommend
two quick things it was to make sure
everyone by middle school got the
beginnings of computer science and
statistics and then adjust your
curriculum after that to now be based in
the fact that every student had
statistics and the beginnings of
computational thinking and algorithms so
that it's then used throughout so you
have to don't have to dumb down the rest
of the classes for some people who
didn't get the quantitative basics that
are the language of the future so I
think that's one basic for all you guys
are ahead of the curve on that but
increasingly people who can't think
statistically are too often deceived or
deceive others unknowingly and the same
thing for the ability to think
algorithmically set that aside
increasingly as machines do more and
more the hardest thing to do right are
the soft skills the ability to manage
others to high-performance manage humans
so some book I saw written to for tech
engineers who wanted to become managers
and it was something called managing
humans so that and the creative process
the ability to invent machines are much
better at routine than they are at
inventing and we need more and more
inventions solving the big problems so
the skills of creatively solving
problems what you'd learn at the
Stanford d.school what Design Thinking
teaches we want more people who come in
Nate with that skill and then the
ability to understand others and help
them rise to be the best they could
possibly be and then help the team arise
to be the best it could possibly be
where every member feels they're doing
the best
worker their lives we we just went
through at the beginning of March we
take our top 400 liters to an off-site
for three days and most of the time was
spent on the issues that we just talked
about right there it is so different
from my own college experience when
analyst first thought yeah we have a few
minutes left about seven minutes left
like to open for audience questions I
think there's at least one microphone
over there one over here raise your hand
please
right here it's got the personal
question how much disposable time do you
get on a daily basis and if you had an
extra hour of time every day what would
you spend it on hmm
well I'm a little bit time management is
not a strength of mine and there are
people who are very intentional and
rigorous on it and I am NOT I have been
able to and I've got the good fortune of
the job I have I can pick what I work on
so I've been able to free up a time the
biggest chunk that I've added over the
last two years
oh it says please repeat the questions
for recording purposes the question was
how much discretionary time do I have
and if I had another hour what would I
do the biggest change I've done to my
time use over the last two years is
amping up what my wife and I do in our
social impact work which is in education
we fund some MS research my wife has
multiple sclerosis but that takes money
but no time where we spend our time is
in education in particular in things
where you can get massive impact per
student that then have the economics to
scale to the millions and millions who
would benefit somewhat inspired by
things that are happening here and we
also tend to focus a lot on the pre-k
ages zero through five because there's
that's not been an area where people
have put as much time so that's been a
big expansion of the time if I had an
hour more time I would do more reading
and understanding things that are at the
cutting edge of change that I don't yet
understand
that would be my incremental hour that's
what I wish I had time to do now right
now I'm reading on blockchain so and
there's a lot of bad reading out there
I'll tell ya
[Laughter]
Christian over here mr. Koch my name is
Derek ax thank you very much for being
here and not sharing with us you had
said when it comes to taxes that into it
should be able to go out and find our
information that sounds fantastic from a
convenience standpoint but how do you
balance that with permission as an
individual do my taxes yeah I really
enjoy the idea at least of being able to
say you know what I'm gonna put down you
know my computer and go fill out a piece
of paper and mail it to the government
yeah yeah you know the permission is for
us the most important thing is our view
of the data that people entrust us with
is that it is not our data it is your
data and we can't do anything with that
that you don't give us explicit and
knowing permission for and that includes
with collecting your information from
other sources we need your permission to
do that and without your permission we
won't but the good news is if you're
straight and honest and tell people for
really what you're gonna do with it and
if it's gonna help improve their life
most will give you that permission so
that's not a barrier for us that's why
we're so open to making it a permission
based system entirely based on your
permission there's a question in this
country I believe yeah Scott my name is
Vince Coley I'm a Silicon Valley mentor
I've been to your institution are into
it and learn design thinking my question
is what is the key difference between a
creator disrupter and a builder so
what's the key difference between a
creator a disrupter and a builder you
know in applying a design thinking lens
I actually find disruptors and creators
very similar I'm not sure I can I think
that's a method if I think in history
you can look back and tell whether
somebody actually
disrupted but it's the same process of
creation it's the same process of seeing
a problem that others have missed or
seeing a way to solve the problem that
others have missed so I think those are
much the same a builder
well there are builders who are not
creators who take a good idea and then
can assemble the parts the people the
mission and but they may not have been
the Creator and then there's some who
can do both Steve Jobs so I think those
are two very different people different
types sometime in the same brain the
creator and the Builder sometimes in
different brains it's a great thing
about teamwork they don't have to be in
the same brain for great results to to
arrive hello my name is Ryan le mo I
want to know what do you think about 20
years so what would the significant
change that we can have in our daily
life oh wait 20 years yes in 20 years
Oh oh boy well I think that biggest
thing about 20 years from now it will be
the stuff that none of us expected
mm-hmm and no futurist imagined at the
Wall Street Journal did some article in
2013 recapping the predictions made by
experts in 2003 could they'd gone out
and asked tech experts for all their
predictions and they said anything that
was kind of a linear extrapolation like
the cost of the computer the speed of
the computer the experts nailed what 10
years later would be like but they said
the experts missed almost everything
else that was important such as social
media totally missed none of the experts
predicted it so number one it'll be the
stuff we don't expect it'll amaze us the
most but what do I expect I think we're
finally going to liberate technology
from prison I we have right here the
most powerful personal technology we've
ever had but look where it is it's in a
pocket or in a purse or you can't see it
and you can't touch it what a waste we
need to attach the technology to at
least the i/o into our body so
can see it that was an attempt for the
Google glass and so that we can interact
with it and so we can hear it why do I
have to put headphones on so ultimately
this will be attached or embedded or
implanted in our body the way that
hearing aids used to be a hundred years
ago 120 years ago it was a metal horn
that you would keep in a purse or
someplace and hold it up to your ear
when you wanted to hear which is
functionally the equivalent of the
backwardness of having to pull this out
of my pocket to use it well now hearing
aids are essentially embedded in your
body and what a much better way that of
life that is well that'll happen to
computing at least the i/o so I think
that's one thing I'm I'm quite excited
about everything well I think in others
will finally change local transit from A
to D solution to a 3d solution right now
we're constrained to operate on you know
a piece of tarmac I mean pavement and
this guy's working to try to make things
use the third dimension so I think
that'll be a big change I think learning
our feedback loops will change and
become omnipresent we were talking a
little offstage the what was the
feedback loop to a taxi driver in most
countries ten years ago on their
performance none and so what kind of
performance did you get awful now what's
the feedback loop to an uber or lyft
driver well they get feedback on almost
every ride and is the performance better
of course feedback enables improved
performance imagine you were practicing
basketball shots and when you made a
shot you didn't see if the ball actually
went in but you'd find it out on your
performance review six months later how
fast would your skills get better well
they probably wouldn't the whole concept
in business of reporting performance
every six or 12 months is so archaic no
wonder the rate of personal improvement
so low I think systems will change and
we're cooking on some ideas to give
people rapid e managers give boss rapid
feedback on the boss's performance how
about daily
wouldn't we all improve faster if we got
daily feedback on the way learning used
to be is you do a paper or something or
you'd study for a week and there'd be a
test and at the next week you learn
whether you learned the material this
week or you do a paper you'd have spent
two weeks on it you submit it the
teacher get back to you two weeks later
what kind of learning feedback loop is
that well now with you know a modern
education you you learn for five minutes
you try something you learn it
immediately if you get it in feedback
loops that happen all the time I think
life will move increasingly toward
constant feedback loops from which we
will all learn to get better so I think
that's a change in life on that note I
have to think you hadn't fortunately out
of time but it was a incredible
privilege to learn from you thank you